sans domicile fixe depuis le 26 août
dernier et nina enceinte de trois mois
et christophe ont dû s'installer en bord
de seine à corbeil essonnes chaîne hôte
d'honneur qu'on a depuis depuis le mois
d'août ici sur corbeil départ on était
en dessous l'arbre et la montée des eaux
on a reculé les tentes et une heure
après c'était devenu une pisciniste ça
c'est la tente où mène aux affaires
généralement bon la moitié de nous à
faire bon ils sont partis chez quelqu'un
qui nous les gardes mais ça c'est notre
demeure voilà la maison attention à vos
pieds donc voilà donc on dormait et vous
nina voilà vous êtes vous êtes une femme
enceinte
vous avez des besoins comment est ce
qu'elle se déroule votre votre vie au
quotidien avec avec ses deux tantes et
cet igloo ici on est à quelques mètres à
peine de la scène mais c'est compliqué
comme je vous l'aï dit plusieurs fois
pour être dans une tente en cents parce
que quand il faut bouger ou même dormir
ou même pour le manque de nourriture
bah y'a pas de ce qu'on a besoin donc
c'est compliqué depuis des années à
l'iga to fit président fondateur de
l'association entraide et solidarité a
aidé plusieurs couples et sdf dans la
rue aujourd'hui
ils se mobilisent pour nina et
christophe notre association les soirs
pas se les voir pour leur apporter un
peu de chaleur humaine mais surtout de
l'espoir le but c'est de les sortir de
cette précarité et de les mettre à
l'abri
c'est pas normal aujourd'hui en france
en 2021 des français et des hommes et
des femmes se retrouvent dans des tentes
à dormir dehors voilà c'est triste mais
c'est la réalité
en attendant de trouver un logement
pérenne l'association a pu leur trouver
un hébergement d'urgence une solution
provisoire pour ce couple qui attend un
heureux événement nous avons en tirer
c'est un peu plus l événement qu un coup
peut attendre
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous
attendez à venir donner tout le bonheur
possible à l'enfant sont épiés
je vais recommencer leur vie dans la rue
parce que moi savent quand les annexions
la rue donc il y en a marre ya un gros
ras le bol leur vie quoi c'est bien
marrant dormir on tente au bout d'un
moment
mais comme si en scène c'est plus
marrant du tout parce que tu te dis à
tout le monde va mon gars semblent vite
et tu veux pas qu'on t'enlève parce que
c'est cet avis et on sent que déjà en
fête et cheval est séparée lui donc moi
je veux coût tripler d'efforts pour m'en
sortir le corps au lavis russie nous a
tous tués moi je travaille dans un
restaurant à la base mais avec le co
vider des saf et tous fermés je me suis
entré aussi je passe dans cette galère à
cause de ça malgré plusieurs demandes de
logement le couple est toujours dans
l'attenté espère rapidement pouvoir
sortir de la rue on a fait la demande de
logements sociaux comme on nous a
demandé donc du coup on a les papiers on
a fait ça par internet aussi on a fait
un contrat ici à eau pour en espérant
qu'ils nous proposent des logements
sociaux
enfin on attend parce que tout se met en
place
le couple sera logé dans cet hôtel
jusque dimanche prochain si aucune
solution n'est trouvée
ils devront retourner dans la rue selon
la fondation abbé pierre il y aurait 300
milles sans domicile fixe en france un
nombre en hausse notamment à cause de la
crise du coronavirus en 2012 et l'insee
recensé 140 milles sans abri dans
l'hexagone